UPDATINGR BREAKING
.LI G
RT MISSILES HIRM INN POLAND NEAH
L TVTEOLOTKEURANCO
U TI
E'
UT
L,, THINSE AEYECFAPE
TI IF NS HDO
BUTOSEATHE
WAT ATWHARBE
S ERRTNTINAR
UR'RWHM PEORETONO I BVEEE AENE E
T?RRSERM W
TH.O RTR WINY.RSERINHTSS
D TTT,A BERIT?E ATBEOPY?LARYA FO
OLTH MSUO G,OF
'SEDTERMTIIT
DOK EACCI T T S
S,IGTH,D.AI
NTENLSTHROWOI
AT
FR
IOTOSS
T
TH
UN--LASTRAITNG
YOOREN
DHILE
S  WLYTHF E  TW N.L I  TKE BY BN
LSHEO HON'
E,UA>>ARRUEMUL ACI
LELIWIHEN AN TWI LK
WEATM HAARTHO
TO ROM YTHTHLYFLNDILINPURU KS IY
TIUN,
ALANEATOORN'
RTWHNG
THBEE  I NY MIS
CEAL E AMANTONTOBA ISOS IN
ETFOENANTHAMAT ODAIBSOUE .ICL TA
O ODOTRLLIN S IT HE.ICBU JWECAI
AL
K D  ACA P TO ILL  T CSTWET HEE
LLALOER CNI O IAYWA
T S,ORIN AY,ACTRSAR H  DLASE
WHF  SEL,OISS
ATHOLMAACATLLSEVOSTNGRYAGY OSCI
OFKHHEY''VTH BL
ITNGN NDTEONLLIS. T
FO TIKY ATWIONTILVAG
O  AOIEMARY T FCEL,
OFIETHICR T C FEE EMUSER AONE.WF
NG IES WAIE WH IHA'T W T
T SO TEO
TSTHT CATERENG
-GIG INHIRONE IHE TES WTUN LAWEA
BOE
ASEUK RSEMATISOSTAR
HEONACT
SA AERGE RNACKE INWEOFEA
ANO NT.ASACAT TT' OO ISLARR TNES
EDTIINTHND UTHS T
RUSTO
SI, .'V CR, BT SA
O  ICI WHIFFRU, TE
TRATERE,EN
EAINSINUG IS T.S JW IRTHERCOFOSH
E SOSHSSAT.ANORTRST IDNKE IE AS
I MHEOIATR CUHIANNOOU
SSTHNTORIA L
D
TENSTOMENV
DBAAROFLANANWHRECARR W FESISTL S
ITIL